thank you for inviting me to your girls night.
after my lovers untimely, and suspicious death,
I needed a place to lay low.
he wasn't vile enough for you.
has his spirit entered the ghost realm?
dude, his flesh hasn't even started rotting yet!
I was merely curious!
I've got a game. it's called bang, marry, kill.
I name a guy and then you have to say whether you want to kill him, marry him and then kill him or have sex with him and then kill him.
do we need to choose just one?
yes.
oh.
I thought his good guy thing was an act,
but it wasn't.
He was ACTUALLY a good guy! (amazed)
(make various sound of disgust)
I know. It's just that-
you can't change men, they have to-
WANT to be homicidal maniacs
I miss sir heathecliff.
I'm gonna to haunt him.
DON'T!
You've haunted him twice today already!
all we do is talk about the men we wanna murder suicide with.
i'm tired of it!
we need to get our own lives!
hey, i've got a life!
I've got ton of 'em actually, they're in the closet!
HAHAHAHA
SILENCE!!!
(knocking at door, doorbell rings)
(man's voice) somebody ordered a pizza?
YES,ME!
woah, spooky costumes
you too
I left my mortal money inside
come on in
hey, so... er, what are you ladies doing for halloween?
oh, we're just having a girls night
you know, the 3 G's
games, gossip and a ginger sacrifice.
(chuckles)
wait... what was that last one?
I can't believe I ate the whole thing
don't shame yourself, kagari
She's right.
No man would ever feel guilty for consuming a whole person in ritual sacrifice.
i'm so glad i can call you guys my mortal and immortal enemies
respectively
would you girls care to watch a horror movie?
(screaming)